We've been continuing to follow all of the
different ways in which Donald Trump is likely to
be tied up with lawyers, legal fees, potentially
in depositions, possible criminal investigations,
and so much more and more and more, it's
likely to be years and years of this.
And it's conceivable that Donald
Trump may soon have to actually
answer questions about the rape allegations
against him under oath. And this relates to
Egin. Carol, you may remember that Egin Carol
accused Donald Trump of having raped her
in a Manhattan department store in the mid
1990s. And when this became a story in 2019,
Donald Trump said he never knew. Carol accused her
of lying to sell a new book and added that she's
not my type. Well, now her lawyers have filed a
defamation suit against Donald Trump. And in fact,
they filed that suit some time ago, but not much
was happening, partially because Donald Trump was
still president of the United States. Now, this is
actually moving forward. The explanation of Trump
is president and this can't move forward for the
time being because he's president. And it would be
in some way damaging or prejudicial for it to move
forward. That is no longer a defense. And Aegean
Carol's lawyers are looking to depose Donald Trump
in this defamation suit. And an attorney for Trump
is not returning requests for comment about this
particular case. But it is conceivable that in
the next could be six months, could be 12 months,
could be 18 months. Donald Trump would actually
have to, under oath answer questions about
the alleged rape that Egin Carol says took
place. This is not the only case in which Donald
Trump may have to answer questions under oath
about an alleged sexual assault that he's accused
of. There is a similar defamation lawsuit from
Summer Zervos. That's, again, a name that may ring
a bell. She was a contestant on Trump's reality
show The Apprentice. And back in 2016, Zervos
also accused Donald Trump of sexual misconduct,
saying that it took place in 2007, initially when
they were at a meeting in New York. And then later
he groped her at a California hotel when they were
supposedly meeting to discuss job opportunities.
Trump not only denied that, but also said Zervos
is a liar. And so Zervos sued Donald Trump for
defamation in 2017. Similarly, that did not really
go anywhere because Donald Trump was president at
the time. And there is, again, the renewed belief
that that may indeed be moving forward soon. Now,
legal experts have said that the idea of the
interference that the Justice Department ran
for Trump on a lot of these cases while
he was president is unprecedented and
that that is not the way that any other president
has been treated while in office. But that,
while still academically interesting, is
in the past. The question now becomes,
are these cases going to move forward?
And is Trump, even as a former president,
going to be compelled to be deposed? And we
don't know the answer yet, but it will be
extraordinarily interesting to follow and see.
Now, if you just zoom out of this for a moment.
It is truly another indicator of the two tiered
justice system that we have that Donald Trump.
It's not even at this point that
Trump hasn't been held accountable
for any of the things that he's
done. They've not been adjudicated
right, even if you believe that. And as we all
should, that you are innocent until proven guilty.
There's no adjudications that are even on the
table because Donald Trump has been able to avoid
even responding to these claims. Donald Trump has
not been deposed when it comes to these complaints
and he's not been put under oath. He's not even
had to step foot in court for anything. So it's
just another reminder that there really are
two justice systems and that having power,
having money, having friends in high places,
having obviously being in the most privileged
position of power that one could arguably be in in
the world as president of the United States. Laws
only matter if there's somebody willing to
enforce them. And one of the things we learned
big picture from the Trump presidency is that the
systems that the founding fathers put in place
as checks and balances to a president for
a president against the president relative
to a president. Arguably weren't strong enough
because as soon as you had a president willing to
ignore and to flaunt his power and to
flout the norms and checks and balances,
nothing happened. Now, you could make the case.
Well, the problem isn't the system. The problem
is that Trump had the Republican Party willing
to help him avoid consequences. Well, then that's
just part of the problems with the system. The
system should be the checks and balances should
be robust enough that you don't have to depend on
a weaponized, friendly Republican Party to keep
a Republican president out of actually having to
face the allegations against them so that that's
the way it is. If you have money and if you have
lawyers who can just tie things up with paperwork,
you can burden just about any system endlessly and
keep yourself out of harm's way. And as we see you
come at Trump and then he may sue you, and then
if you try to sue Trump for defamation, then he'll
just figure out a way to avoid being deposed.
And a lot of this hopefully was only because he
was president. We will see. We will see. I'm
not, like, super optimistic. I have to say